very disturbing story a Donald Trump has
a deputy assistant named Sebastian
gorkha he was recently photographed
wearing a medallion associated with the
Nazi friendly regime that ruled Hungary
during World War two sort of odd and
people started looking into this and the
metal is part of an order of merit
founded in nineteen twenty by miklós
horthy Hungary's anti-semitic ruler and
Hitler's close ally who was officially
designated by the United States State
Department is a Nazi collaborator that's
right Trump's assistant wears a pin that
is a reference to a Nazi collaborator we
have some pictures of gorkha wearing
this paraphernalia at events related to
donald trump other than being downright
bizarre and creepy it's also incredibly
disturbing gorkha is a hungarian descent
told breitbart I'm a proud American now
and I wear that metal now and again why
to remind myself of where I came from in
2006 gorkha defended the use of the
r-pod flag by people in hungary which
was the symbol of the Arrow Cross party
who killed thousands of Jews in World
War two from 2002 2007 gorkha was active
in Hungarian politics and had close ties
to the far right in Hungary he was
working with openly racist and
anti-semitic groups in public figures
collaborated with members of a Hungarian
neo-nazi political party to create a new
far-right party that had the goal of
putting Christianity into Hungary's
Constitution he's attended events with
Hungary's most well-known far-right
extremists he wrote explicitly racist he
wrote articles for an explicitly racist
and anti-semitic newspaper called Maggie
our demócrata the US State Department
has officially recognized that newspaper
as anti-semitic and as holocaust denying
and Donald Trump Deputy Assistant
Sebastian gorkha wrote for that
newspaper also worked for the Hungarian
national committee which published their
official publication in use in 2004
wrote we should get Jews out in fact we
need to take back our country from
take back our stolen fortunes after all
these upstarts are sucking on our blood
getting rich off of our blood embraced
by the outright he's been on news
outlets saying that foreign leaders
should be afraid of truant very few
people are talking about this Pat but
this guy is clearly less powerful than
like Steve Bannon for example arguably a
far more dangerous extremists and isn't
it pretty strange that Trump associates
himself with so many anti-semitic people
yeah especially because I don't believe
he is himself I might his daughters
Jewish his son-in-law is Jewish and he
says that he's the least anti-semitic
person he's probably the type of guy who
holds a lot of stereotypically
anti-semitic beliefs but doesn't
consider himself someone who actively
did I like Jews as a result but that
type of thing can breed an environment
where this type of guy ends up standing
next to you and advising you especially
when you listen to the words that he
speaks i mean his whole campaign message
was america first and that has its
background in a very anti-semitic
message not wanting to support Europe in
World War two from the outset or let him
European refugee and by the way gorka an
immigrant to the United States born in
the UK to hun garion parents what he's a
white guy is not the type of immigrant
that we need to be worried about
everybody relax this is the good type of
immigrant